is there something I don't know if
you've been following but the the quick
amazing development of language models
uh the neural network
natural language processing systems
dialogue systems
um
do you think there's some possibility of
using
so there's these incredible neural Nets
that can have open-ended dialogue
basically chat Bots yep I've seen some
incredible demos I do think it's coming
I don't know when yeah
um and there's a little bit of a
question like what's ready for
real deployment and release
versus
hey let's use that to generate some
things that is then static that we're
giving to the players
um versus yeah it's generated on the fly
but it's definitely coming it's
definitely coming and I think you'll see
it in the types of games that we do it
has great you know application I love
the idea that you'll be using ad to
design different uh NPCs and then
testing if they're if they're good
enough if they're like um a little too
crazy you don't want like the the super
right but if we go back to it being
reactive some of that bot stuff
you know it's pretty it's incredible
it's then Translating that into voice
and then is that being done
by the client is it being done on a
server is it baked into the game there's
like different flavors of it
so there's still computational
challenges like how do you actually make
that happen right well what about
oh in terms of creating the feeling of
an NPC
uh what's the role of voice actors and
awesome yeah we we work with a ton of
voice actors
and they bring so much to it and and
that's the thing
um
they you know we can write some stuff
and and the best ones get in there and
make it so much better or even ad-lib
things and so we we do a lot of voice
recording and we used to do it kind of
like at the end of the project
and now we do it throughout we start
really early and we just start recording
so we're recording
for years and years literally probably
three years four years so part of the
actual experience of the recording will
help Define the characters and the tone
of the game and we'll go back sometimes
and hey we really like this we want more
of this let's write let's do another
session or
hey we don't think this character is
actually working we want you to do it
you're going to be someone else now
sorry that got cut
do you ever
try to sort of imagine that people fall
in love with the characters with the
NPCs I do
like I mean do they get really attached
to the oh yeah I mean I've done it in
games these are like close friends right
like you can like you missed them 100
isn't that part actually like whenever
I'm playing a game and there is you know
if there's like a friendship option or
make friends or a romance thing I I find
those moments really
I enjoy them I find them pretty
impactful emotionally to what we're
doing and so we've done a little bit of
it it's one of the things that we
actually have pushed in Starfield
so we have a number of companions but
for them
we go you know I won't say super complex
romantic but but more complex
relationships than we've had
in terms of
not just some you know state of they
like you or they don't like you but they
can be they can be in love with you
and dislike something you did and be
pissed at you temporarily and then come
back to loving you so that that
relationship status if it's complicated
that that they're they're existing in
that gray area is complicated we're not
dating we're just
or well it's in a lot of games you know
previous stuff you just work your way up
they like you more and more and more and
more and now you're in a relationship
now you're in and you and when you make
him upset you drift out of like it never
happened you know you drift out of it
whereas we wanted one where okay we can
be in a relationship and yeah
um
we've committed to each other in some
way but I just did something that really
made you angry
yeah and as opposed to just drifting out
of that status you're in a temporary
I don't like what you did State wow so
some greater degree of complexity in the
relationship with the company a little a
little bit a little bit a little bit I
was talking about I don't want to
oversell that part but sure my point is
I think those things where you meet a
character in a game and you do spend
time with them a companion in a game and
it leads to romance you know myself and
others and I find a lot of players
those moments are really really
impactful and special to them because
they did put in the time
that's another thing that I always come
at it with which is I think people don't
play video games they sometimes think
like oh that's I don't know that's a
waste of time or that's not real that's
not like you're not getting a lot out of
that like we haven't really experienced
it in the way that you can because
these moments that I spent in games not
the ones I made other ones when I was
growing up or even now those are that is
important time to me like I love those
moments I felt really like proud of what
I accomplished
and we want people to have that in our
games and the fact that they've had they
have had those experiences and we hear
from them and how important it is to
them it's like
no this is this is really really special
yeah it's uh
it's fun I mean from from a game design
perspective I wonder if you can honor
the time you spent together with the
game because
um
you know sometimes there's a heartbreak
at the end of the game like when you're
when you when you leave a game there's a
yeah it's a really complicated
relationship actually because when you
leave a game it's almost like leaving a
romantic partner because
I think you spent so much meaningful
time together
and
there's a sense in which it was uh
it was ephemeral like it right this this
is not this didn't happen it didn't
really happen it was good it was like he
went to Vegas he got drunk and stuff for
like and now Life Goes On
I wonder if there's a way to sort of
always carry that with you I mean I
guess with words you can kind of share
with others like this it's weird I don't
like
now that we're in the age where you have
achievements and you can look at your
library and see your hours and games
like that's like it's almost like a
scrapbook now like I wish
one of my wishes was like I wish I had
that achievement list for everything
like back to the late 70s like every
game you play right when yeah yeah like
you I mean that's one of the cool things
with Xbox like we're moving towards that
direction it'd be cool to be from like
childhood the first time you play video
game it will actually tell you what is
the first game you know what yeah kids
today they will have that they will have
that
and see you could look back and see oh
my God I put a thousand hours in
Daggerfall what is the first and my last
save was
19.
um man I don't know golden ax maybe I'm
trying to think what was the first game
I've ever played
uh no it's probably a Commodore 64 games
yeah
um yeah arcade games